welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz and this is
a another edition of our graduate
entry-level focused podcast series where
we're sitting down with recruiters who
may have recently graduated
or are early on in their recruitment
career to sort of
uncover one how they're thriving
in their first couple of years what
challenges they're working through
and most importantly to find out what
advice they can give all of you
listening who may be also early on in
your recruitment career or at least
considering a career in recruitment
so i'm really excited to be joined by a
man today so amanda before
we get started if you could introduce
yourself let everyone know who you
are for those that may not know who you
are and uh we'll get into it
sure so i graduated in 2019 from aston
ironically i did a placement year in
recruitment before so
was well versed to the to the sort of
place the industry
um and now i'm at interx group which
we're a cloud
data microsoft farm in you know
operating europe and america
and i've been there for around six
months now as a consultant so
yeah pretty excited to speak to you
today i love that
so let's unpack this then so you did a
placement year in recruitment
like so did you want it do you want to
get into recruitment yeah so
kind of it was more like administration
recruitment so the university would
advertise
free jobs and we would say to the people
you know
the students advertise this speak to the
clients and say look
we've placed this job here how many
people have we placed then we'd have to
collate with a lot of reports
talk to these clients on a day-to-day
basis not like the hardcore
sales that this is but it's sort of that
10 of the job so
that's kind of what intrigued me yeah
yeah fair so like obviously when you
graduated then like talk to me about
what was it recruitment that you set out
to get into was it an accident like
what no how did that happen 100 wanted
to get into it because of this placement
i typed in a i was doing my placement i
loved it
and i typed in a job similar to this i
didn't really know anything about time
i'll be honest with you
sure and then i saw a hundred grand a
year all that stuff that they say
um i like that part but i also like the
part of speaking with candidates
speaking with clients and
having a busy life um and then yeah
pretty much
when i graduated i was doing in the
middle of my exams i did
three days at my previous company of
like assessment days
and got the job before i graduated so i
started pretty much
instantly after love that yeah so
what uh what i'd love to hear from you
then is like what
what skills or experience do you think
has recruitment given you that maybe you
least expected
i think you know people talk about the
resiliency and hard work but for me it's
that sort of commercial business acumen
you know
you're not just someone who finds a cv
and places them but
you're speaking to people about their
needs challenges you understand the
wider business so
it really gives you that business
perspective more than anything
and i really like that facet i think
that's the most underrated trait that
comes out of recruitment rather than
just saying
here's a cv let's place it yeah yeah i
love that so
talk to us a bit more about that because
i know when we sort of prepared for this
that was something that you think
like if i'm listening to this right now
if you can actually you know make the
time and space to really understand
how you can cut away that commercial
acumen and that that sort of business
understanding
like why why do you think that's
underrated or why do you think that's
important out of interest yeah so i'll
give you an example i'm speaking to a
lot of c-suites from you know these
fortune 500 companies in america you
know
they're famous in their own world what
you've got to be able to do
is relate to these people like you're
speaking to them as if you're one of
them
if you can't relate to them how can you
have the conversation to uncover their
pain
under uncover their needs you've kind of
sometimes got to go to these
guys and say you know you're in this
space
here's the problem here's the issue um
and tell them what's wrong and they they
really appreciate that because
it shows you're sort of on their level
rather than that sort of
subordinate to client perspective i
think it shows that you can be a value
ad then
that's the part i really like the most
is not controlling that's the wrong word
but
speaking to people like you're on the
same level you know yeah
that's kind of why and how how can how
can people go about cultivating that
early on then
is that is that something that you've
really tried to learn in your own time
or like how have you
got better yeah i guess working on that
commercial muscle because
clearly there would have been a bit of
learning there oh 100
no great question i think where you
learn that is the reading outside the
books the
looking looking at the news you know for
example during coronavirus
we made a tactic and i made a tactic to
only go at companies that would be busy
during this time the logistics the
pharma
rather than going for companies that
maybe have probably
how do i put it um yeah had a difficult
time yeah
yeah and that's kind of where it comes
from and then you understand the pain
from one client
and you know that another client's going
through the same issue so you take that
to them
and almost tell them that that's your
mistake so that's that commercial side i
think that's
really underrated because how can you
let people buy into you
if you don't know anything about their
world yeah
honestly i love the fact that this is
your mindset towards
like it's so easy at the beginning of
your career just to think about
like i'm i'm helping this person get a
job or like and
you're already thinking about the whole
picture and
understanding like you said what these
people's pains are
and obviously having the right people in
the right seats or you getting them the
right people
is obviously part of that solution but
you're already thinking about the bigger
picture
which i i absolutely love that um talk
to me about
i think people would be interested a lot
of people early on
can sometimes obviously be quite
fearful of speaking to people that may
be
uh older than them more experienced in
them bit of imposter syndrome like oh
who am i to like it seems like you're
really quite confident in talking to
these people right and
i think some people in your shoes may
feel like oh wow i'm supposed to see
sweet level people like and i'm
obviously undergraduate in 2019 i
haven't
got anywhere near as much experience as
them like how have you dealt with that
of interest has that been an issue
how have you overcome if someone is
listening to this that maybe is a bit
feeling fearing from that bit of
imposter syndrome like oh maybe i'm not
too experienced to speak i don't know
what how what's been your journey with
that you know it seemed tough right at
the start
as everyone does you see that client and
the pedestal and you can speak together
it's like
like for days but i've actually found
that it's swung the other pendulum what
what has happened for me is i've
realized that on the business side i've
done this before i can speak to these
guys i've got people in my family who
are in the business side as well so i'll
speak to these guys and say look what
are your challenges what are your issues
take that to the client itself and they
will pretty much agree i think
regardless of whatever
level you are in management you have the
same issues in terms of
um challenges with hiring challenge with
with business
and the pendulum for me is swing so i
used to put candidates on
um i used to speak to candidates for
days and you know i can respect them
forever
but now it's more shifting towards the
client side because i'm in a technical
field now sometimes i don't get that
stuff
so i can easily relate to these guys
because i've done business i read the
books that they do it's really immersing
yourself in that world but
that's something i enjoy i think you've
got to inherently enjoy speaking about
this stuff rather than
forcing it yeah fair enough interesting
so what what have been some of your
obviously we all i'm sure you would have
heard it but
a lot of people could sort of articulate
that the first year in recruitment first
two years in recruitment uh bloody
difficult
maybe the most difficult parts of your
working career if you end up working
in recruitment for the long haul like
what have been some of the challenges
you've had to be
that you've had to work through so far
first is the mindset and
getting into what not only from working
hard but
making your life catered towards that i
think you've got to have a lot of
sacrifices
i didn't necessarily understand that to
start i was with a lot of
high performing people in another in my
old company and
i was just thinking how do i get there
i'm miles away
so it's really about stripping it back
for me looking at sort of the basics
whether that's
you know the eating right i'm starting
to get there no i'm not perfect
um the exercise and then it all follows
into place i think
you've got to immerse yourself in this
life rather than sort of taking it as a
nine to five
that's my honest opinion for the first
year at least just to build your ground
but it has been tough in terms of that
first year a lot of challenges
when i did that recruitment placement
year it was nothing
like and i came in to my first day
thinking i know this all i did really
well in my placement
and then it was a different world the
leads the the reference calls
everything there's so much that you need
to think about so strip it back
keep it simple and then the rest will
follow that's how i look at it
yeah okay interesting so i guess
what what what advice would you give
to yourself if you were just graduating
again entering recruitment
for the first time knowing what you know
now out of interest keep it simple
um i used to really go the complicated
way thinking
in my head look i need to do this this
this every day i was thinking of
innovative ways that probably didn't
work
but i thought would have worked but just
keep the basics and the rest will follow
that's how i look at it and
because otherwise you can end up working
out too much working too much
i'm not getting any results which is
what i found in my first place i was
really burnt out towards the end of it i
wasn't seeing the best results
and yeah and then really when i started
here it's
following the basics and the rest is
again follows
i keep on saying that but it's true yeah
yeah talk to me about
because i think that is definitely one
of the challenges i think especially for
people early on in their
recruitment career can burn out or like
just because there's just so much you
can do
you want to prove people write the prove
people that you can do it
like obviously like you said towards the
end there you're maybe feeling a bit
burnt out and these sorts of things so
what things have you done now then to
avoid that have you
so it seems like obviously you're
thinking about the whole picture so
instead of just putting all your energy
into work you're thinking about yeah
what you're putting into your body
you're trying to make space for exercise
like you're trying to obviously
obviously the the sort of holistic
thing rather than just putting it into
work like i don't know what if someone
maybe is feeling a bit like wow i'm
literally
just absolutely working my socks off at
the moment i don't know how much longer
i can
i can do this for like what would you
say to them i'd say
look strip it back a bit you've got your
work day
focus on what ben completely percent do
the basics in that particular time i.e
the calls
the admin um the the linkedin piece
uh for example like yourself you promote
do all that within your work then the
rest of the day
focus on other areas that will tailor to
the work so again i'm not perfect for
this i'll be honest with you but
the exercise in the eating healthy that
all feeds into
um your work it sort of prepares your
mind but
really don't spend a hundred percent
like you said in work
focus on other areas and the rest will
follow but really do immerse yourself
into that work as well you know you've
got to
yeah so okay cool interesting so
what what advice so like if i'm
listening to this right now and i'm
like i might have just graduated um
i might come across some jobs on about
recruitment
might repeat my interest like what what
advice would you give me if i was just
starting out
what into interview or recruitment
itself
well i'll definitely get some for your
thoughts on like the
interview tips but i guess like if i if
i'm someone
so let me reframe that so like if i'm
someone that has
landed a recruitment job and i start
tomorrow
like what what would you say to me if me
and you were down the pub and i was like
mate i'm just i'm about to start
recruitment
like you did like no more no yeah what
would you say to me
yeah don't chat [ __ ] a lot of the time i
think is one
people yeah people got people going they
think that their their next month is
going to be the biggest month they think
that they're going to do xyz
just focus on your work um learn every
day even outside of work learn whether
that's not recruitment but the business
side that i mentioned the mindset
think about all of these things because
eventually they all add up into a bubble
and that sort of compound effect comes
and then it all when you least expect it
it's like a bus coming three times and
you only get you know
when you've been waiting for ages it
will all follow into place but
really focus on your craft first focus
on the basics
whether that's the candidate stuff
getting kind of information candidates
build up your client spread and then
eventually from there
it will all follow i promise that it's
happened for me
yeah okay talk to me about because i
remember seeing your
videos and and stuff on on linkedin like
how
like what about obviously there'll be a
lot of people uh
graduating there'll be a lot of people
obviously on the job market trying to
enter work for this uh for the um first
time obviously
super competitive so like what what
advice would you give to people to like
stand out amongst
their peers and amongst other graduates
that might be trying to get into the
recruitment industry and be applying for
the same jobs
yeah this is my fault i think this is my
forte here like i said
i used to do the linkedin videos it
doesn't quite fit in with the brand i'm
in now in tech
but really what the focus is right now
i'd say in terms of interviews and
standing out
all you need to do i think people would
neglect this but research the company
that you're interviewing like crazy
if you want them to go into a company
and you really like it all i say is
look at three different facts about the
company that you would have to dig deep
in on the internet
explain this in the interview that you
know this and ask questions around it
get the interviewer talking more in the
interview what you want to do in my
opinion
is looking at 60 of these guys talking
and 40
you you want to get them talking you
want to get them selling the role back
to you
inadvertently you are more when they
talk to you as well
you can then play off the fact of what
they talk to you about
and sell against that if that makes
sense i don't know how to word that but
you can sort of tailor your answers to
what they say but really go in with the
mindset to learn in an interview
and then you can tailor your questions
but really go in with facts
that you know that not many other people
would know and really just going
confident you know
it's only a conversation look at it as
you're having a chat between me and you
today
this is not a person like a client to a
candidate subordinate level
this is a peer to peer they want you as
well it's a hard market out there to
find talent
people are you're gearing for talent now
and recruitment and
it's tough so you can easily stand out
and then talk to me about because i know
we spoke about this like
what about so obviously the the computer
was that before it was a different
market
so like yeah yeah so like talk to me
about what about
like what about thinking about what
market i should go into or
i don't know what what's been what's
obvious i know that you're in in the
market that you're in now but
i guess did you spend much time thinking
about the type of industry that you
wanted to recruit in
what was your journey with that first uh
first sort of when i joined i was
looking at professional services i
didn't want to do any sort of
warehouse in construction yeah that kind
of stuff that wasn't myself
yeah so i did finance i you know i
looked at the robert half company it's
huge right
everyone knows that that chord ladder um
it wasn't quite familiar and i just feel
like it's very bureaucratic
um the commission's not very good um
there's not much say um but the finance
market itself good but then what i saw
was
obviously the tech market itself there's
so many different areas of tech that you
can sort of double down in one area one
niche
and there's so much more money to be
made because we're only at the start of
it so i chose that one for the money
aspect but
two because the guys in these fields
they
have a lot of power in terms of the
business so speak to these guys
and you can unlock doors like no no
tomorrow because you look at one
vertical
tech they could be hiring 200 people but
overall they could be hiring thousands
so
it's the money aspect but also that
business-to-relationship aspect but
if i would say if you're going through
recruitment and you want to have that
sort of
relationship with a client look at the
professional services
don't look at the construction of the
warehouse unless you have
the the passion for that but if you want
to make serious money look at the
professional services 100
and what about what are your thoughts on
like being in a space that you're
like personally interested passionate
about is that something that
has helped you that you thought about do
you think that's something people should
be thinking about
yeah hundreds i think that is a key when
i was doing finance i actually did
an element of financing my degree i did
a business degree so there was elements
of finance so
i understand these guys and i was kind
of recruiting for people i graduated
with
which is crazy so it was kind of like
talking with friends
that's a hundred percent a factor you
know have an interest like i'll give you
an example right now
i'm in tech i don't have a 100 passion
for it but when i'm speaking with
clients they're talking a lot about
business and
that's a conversation i could talk to
them for an hour an hour and a half
i enjoy it but i couldn't have that
conversation if i was in
looking high volume i don't know retail
or yeah yeah
so is is is recruitment really as
intense as everyone
says it is yeah yeah um
you know i think the first again i'm
only like a year and a half in
i'm still in that phase where you're
still grinding working hard doing extra
hours
that's what's need to be done i think
unless unless you're
really super focused efficient in your
hours which i'll be honest i'm not
i i tend to be focused and then have a
drab of a day where i'm kind of
no um you know i look yeah you admit
that
but you need to work the extra hours
whether that's to add to your clients
add to your candidates to your extra
admin linkedin
for the first year at least then when
you build your client spreads your
your candidate pool and you can fill
jobs like that
that's when you can start looking at it
as less intense more like a nine to five
nine to six but
for the first year year two years you're
looking at probably
in a normal world eight to seven eight
to eight in my opinion
interesting and then talk to me about
sir i feel like a lot of people can
struggle when they make that transition
from like candidate to do more client
work
because a lot of people typically start
with obviously i i started there where
yeah you might deal with some clients
but it's existing clients
um but most of the time you're speaking
to candidates yeah
what's been your it seems like like you
said the pendulum has gone
towards clients now and it's something
that you're building more and more
confidence with
if i'm listening to this and i'm sort of
alone in my career
i'm maybe now starting to do more client
work or be expected to do more business
development
pick up my own clients like obviously it
seems like you're
obviously on the other side of this now
or obviously still on that journey but
you've obviously maybe worked through
maybe some of those initial
challenges like what would you like
what's worked for you what's helped you
get better at that client side
definitely no very good question comes
back
i keep on mentioning it but that
business perspective right you've got to
understand these guys you've got to
immerse yourself in their space
but also i think what's helped me is
let's say you're speaking
i'm just speaking completely from the
market now you're speaking to an
engineer
um they're probably on about they're
probably more hands-on coding technical
people
go to speak to architects and managers
first about a
potential role so speak to these guys as
a candidate
understand their world understand what
they want and what their perspective is
in terms of hiring say look
you're going to be in your next role
you're going to be hiring and
talk to them about this and you'll
naturally gain more confidence
you'll gain more confidence in speaking
to these guys and you can go on the next
call
and frame that up to a client when you
call call them or when you speak to
another client and flip them around a
job
that's how i look at it so start with
the basics you know it's always hard
going to be
called bd that that that's just the
world so speak to peop
senior people as candidates first
understand and then you'll get more
confidence when you're on that bd call
because you already know from the people
that you've spoken to in the past
what they like what they dislike what
their challenges are and you can sort of
tell them you're trying to tell them the
challenges then
and they really respect that because
you're going in as a trusted advisor
rather than someone who's
setting up them yeah i love that so
actually
when you make that transition it's a
good spend of time to actually
instead of straight away trying to speak
to hiring managers and clients about
yeah hiring needs going with that
conversation actually
start your knowledge gathering and
speaking to them from a candidate
perspective
but obviously yeah that's bd time
obviously because yeah
that's interesting yeah and obviously
you always hear around flipping
flipping hiring managers into candidates
and stuff like that but actually
that that to thinking back that could
that's a really smart way to
just yeah i think it's what you're it's
what you're saying is
giving yourself an opportunity to find
out about these people's worlds and when
you do have more of that information
then you can get better at framing the
conversation
when you are then going with hey we
solve these typical types of problems
like is it worth having a conversation
around your hiring needs and when you
are doing that bd stuff
it is very smart right i think what
you've got to do on that perspective as
well
let's say you get a p let's say you're
speaking to a senior candidate and you
understand
you speak about the business so you're
speaking to an architect for example in
my world
they're saying that they're on the staff
short staff they use
xyz as a partner like a kpmg or yeah
whoever it is you can then go to that
hiring manager that you know as their
manager and say look i know this like
project uh yeah yeah i can add value
here
i know a lot about what you're looking
for i've got a guy here who does xyz
really building up the candidate side
and then taking to the clients but that
flipping back i'll be honest with you
that's how i get
every bit of my success in the market
you know i'm not much we're not much of
a cold calling
we're very much flipping back
understanding the
the business and then that's how we've
resorted in massive accounts
well i'm sorry i should say yeah talk to
me about
i guess just before before we finish
last couple of questions
so what about so like you said one of
the things that really impeached your
interest
was like the potential of like earnings
and stuff don't have to give me like the
exact things but like
obviously sometimes people can be really
light sort of wooed by this or like
like a lot of people want to know can i
actually earn 40 grand in my first year
whatever obviously you're
six months in with interx right but like
from from what you've experienced so far
like again there's nuance here depends
how hard you want to work your market
all these types of things but
if i'm listening to this right now and i
don't know yeah i'm looking at
opportunities to get into recruitment
can see the basic the bases around 20
and 25 grand in between there but the ot
is 50 80 grand first year 30 grand like
what
from your experience so far what would
you say is like a realistic achievable
number in that
first year that maybe you're aiming for
or just from the context you've
experienced so far
out of interest yeah i'm not aiming you
know i'd love that 100 grand or anything
but
it's very very very unlikely that's
going to happen you've got to look at
that as year 2 and year 3.
the first year is about building i
wouldn't even think about the money in
the first year i'm still not thinking
i love that i don't yeah yeah i'm not
thinking about that right now
build all your information and then in
the second year let it explode
you know build up your candidate spread
and then just follow the process
the money will come um but just focus on
doing the outcome first it's a patient
game you know especially in my world
the usa it takes a lot longer to build
up but the fees are so bigger
so look at it now as focus focus focus
and in the year you'll be reaping the
benefits it's
it's not all about the money it's about
if you enjoy your work as well and
that's
that's exactly what i do i'm not in this
for the money i i love it
i love what i do yeah no i love that
fair enough
but realistically what what we're saying
then if our ground 40 grand like what
would you say
to your mates like i reckon if if you do
if you work really hard
give it a crack this is maybe what you
might be able to earn like realistically
in your opinion yeah well for me for me
you're probably looking about 40 45 and
then the next year you can go on but
again it depends on the market right you
know i'm doing yeah yeah
usa cloud for example big fees but
whether if you're in the uk
lower fees but you can probably get in
quicker it really depends but
40 grand i'd say yeah i'd say yeah i
just wanted to get your thoughts on that
so thank you
uh so look last two questions firstly
then i know
i've sort of asked you this in a few
different ways but just just to make
this really practical
like top tips for success in the first
six twelve months of recruitment
what what what are they from you good
and much of what
i keep i've said a few times right you
immerse yourself in the environment in
the environment
don't think about the money just think
about sort of doing well
um hitting your kpis initially because
the rest of it it sort of is like a
bubble
it will follow on don't think like me
i'll be exact i'll be honest
i i was in my first i'll be thinking
crap where's the money where's the money
it's not about that it's about building
up focusing on the process
and keeping how do i put it just keeping
humble as well i think that's the that's
the main thing
just always willing to learn um because
the the thing is when you're first in
recruitment you you're not gonna earn a
lot of money
let's be honest very unlikely so show
your managers show your bosses that
you've got that extra layer that
commitment that you will in a year
because it is all a money game for
bosses right
yeah and then final question why
obviously you always hear recruitment
starts as a career as an accident like
why do you think people should actually
be considering
recruitment as a career choice rather
than a accident
from your point of view you're unlocking
other business needs right you're
not just you're not just putting people
in a role that if you're looking at it
as that as a game
that's the wrong game to be in you've
got to look at it as you're helping a
business
you're actually providing value and
therefore relationships build
therefore you get more business more
money it's a full cycle i don't look at
this as
like a one-year job like other people
have i look at this as a pedestrian and
stuff that you can do in recruitment's
crazy not only in money but building
your own business which should be
everyone's goal
um and then from there um the success
just follows but
it is a career it's not just a one-year
gig like a lot of a lot of graduates
come in to do
yeah i love that amanda thank you so
much i really appreciate you
coming and getting involved with this uh
i love i just
feel like that i just feel like you're
yeah just really committed to
your career i can sense just more and
more confidence is building the way
you're talking about things so
excited to to see where you are in
another year two years time
on your recruitment journey but thank
you so much for for coming on and
getting involved and
i'm sure if anyone does have any
questions or want to put your brain or
anything that you'd be happy to to help
and connect with your linkedin
definitely please do yeah yeah thank you
so much thank you